[Music]
welcome i'm cory keller i'm an assistant
professor at stanford university and i'm
excited to present to you today on
electrophysiology guided brain
stimulation
this is what a patient handed me in my
first year of residency it was a note
that said i'm afraid of this evaluation
process the diagnosis depends on me what
i say and i don't trust myself with
anything i never had i say something one
moment but later it's not what i feel so
how will they know i want them to use
machine slash technology to examine my
brain to really know what is wrong with
me
this
perfectly aligns with my career goals to
develop objective personalized and
real-time diagnostic and treatment
solutions for mental health disorders
i hope at the end of this talk you can
take with you that interventional
psychiatry is an emerging field with
tons of potential
but to personalize and increase efficacy
we need to fill some large gaps
that includes developing objective brain
biomarkers to monitor during treatment
mapping these brain biomarkers to
multi-dimensional stimulation parameters
and optimizing real-time monitoring for
closed-loop stimulation
if we can do that we will have a
personalized treatment with minimal side
effects that can be applied to any brain
circuit and any neuropsychiatric
disorder
so let's start with depression
everyone knows depression is the leading
cause of disability worldwide and covet
has only made those numbers worse
about a third of our patients have
treatment resistant depression
for these patients we have this space of
interventional psychiatry
we have our tms or transcranial magnetic
stimulation devices all of which are fda
cleared
we have our other brain stimulation
methods some of which are cleared and
some are coming down the pipeline
and this interesting space of
psychedelics
i'm going to focus my talk on tms
because it is the most common outpatient
procedure for treatment resistant
depression
now tms is everywhere at this point it's
in every major hospital and in many
outpatient clinics we have multiple
different treatment protocols
all of which are clinically effective
based on randomized clinical trials
we have these interesting novel
treatment patterns like accelerated
theta bursts
but we still lack a mechanistic
understanding of how tms actually gets
into the brain and modulates brain
circuits
we don't have these brain biomarkers to
stratify predict and track outcome
and we can't change this biomarker or
biomarkers because we don't have them
yet
so what do we know
we know that single pulses of tms
generate time-varying magnetic fields
that penetrate the skull and induce
action potentials we know this in
non-human primates that single pulses of
tms can elicit action potentials within
five milliseconds of the pulse
this is not true with stam stimulation
we also know in humans that single
pulses of t-mass applied to the motor
cortex can elicit a motor evo's
potential through the corticospinal
tract so no one's going to dispute that
tms can get into the brain and cause
action potentials
what is more controversial is how
repetitive tms or patterned tms
actually modulates brain circuits and
induces brain plasticity
so this plasticity idea derives from
animal models where high frequency 100
hertz electrical stimulation to the
hippocampus can induce long-lasting
changes
in the epsp or ipsp or the evo's
potential
bring that up to motor cortex and turn
down the frequency so you don't cause
seizures
we have our initial 10 hertz tms
treatment
in this treatment while some studies
show an increase in the motor or both
potential when you apply 10 hertz
stimulation to motor cortex
other studies
are not so clear in this study there's
not a consistent effect
of how 10 hertz rtms to the motor cortex
modulates the motor of both potential
and a more recent study that looked at
continuous theta burst and inhibit and
intermittent theta burst which are
thought to be inhibitory and excitatory
respectively
across a lot of subjects had no net
change in the motor of both potential
so even in the motor cortex where we
have a really high signal to noise
output in that motor of both potential
it's not super clear what these tms
protocols do
and furthermore outside of the motor
cortex is even less clear
so what do we think we're doing well we
think in depression we have a hypoactive
dorsolateral prefrontal cortex or dlpsc
and a hypoconnected frontal parietal
network as a result
this decrease in top-down inhibition
of the default mode network in yellow
and the salience network in red allow
those networks to become hyper-connected
and are thought to underlie a lot of the
depressive symptoms that we see
and we think tms can upregulate that
dlpfc regen
normalize the frontal parietal network
in blue and normalize the amount of
top-down inhibition in the default mode
network and saliency network there's
some imaging
studies to show this but not a ton
what we'd like to be able to do is given
an abnormal brain circuit in a disorder
we want to know what the fundamental
principles are
to turn up or turn down that circuit
if we can do that we have a treatment
that has unlimited applications with
minimal side effects
tms is already fda cleared for all these
disorders in both
and my guess is that five years from now
all of these disorders will be cleared
now there is a hidden agenda here and
that's with basic neuroscience a basic
human neuroscience we don't have the
tool
to causally enhance
or inhibit
a given network and so if we could do
that with tms in a very similar manner
we could explore
what
the functional and behavioral
downstream effects are from modulating
that circuit which would be hugely
beneficial
so why aren't we there
well it's a number of reasons the first
like i said before is we lack this
objective brain biomarker that could be
monitored in the clinic
could measure target engagement and
relate to symptom change
we don't have a great understanding of
this multi-dimensional parameter space
we have this two-dimensional space where
we have 10 hertz one hertz and theta
burst stimulation these are our
treatments for tms for depression
but outside of this we don't know what
these other patterns and other
frequencies do
furthermore this is our two-dimensional
space we have a 10-dimensional space
location frequency state dependence
number of sessions intercession spacing
i can go on and on and we need to start
moving towards this multi-dimensional
analysis
to better understand the interactions
between these stimulation parameters
we
doing tms studies in the lab or in the
clinic is enormously resource heavy
a tms study typically takes hundreds of
patients treated for a month or more
and that has a huge burden on the lab or
the clinic
i want to bring that down to an n of one
study
and a one day study where we can in a
crossover manner study the effects of
let's say 10 different treatments
in a low dimensional space
and eventually we need to move towards
monitoring in real time and adapting
treatment with closed-loop solutions
so this is our lab
we focus on neuromodulation and human
electrophysiology
the lab deconstructs brain stimulation
to establish fundamental mechanisms
underlying human neuroplasticity and
develop real-time closed-loop treatments
for mental health disorders
we do this by developing novel methods
to probe the human brain in a causal and
directional manner
we try to better understand the
fundamental mechanisms underlying human
brain plasticity
and create real-time closed-loop
solutions
we use three preparations to do this
the first is a fully invasive
intracranial approach so these are
patients with medically intractable
epilepsy that undergoes surgery and they
get up to 300 electrodes placed into
their brain
we can using focal electrical
stimulation stimulate certain brain
regions like the dlpfc
in a pattern that is very similar to
what we do in the clinic let's say 10
hertz stimulation
and then we can explore using these
intracranial electrodes that have very
high signal to noise
and high spatial and temporal resolution
we can explore the effects of that
repetitive stimulation pattern
now the caveat here is this is
electrical stimulation and not dms and
these are epilepsy patients so the
generalizability is called into question
on the other side of the spectrum is a
fully non-invasive approach this can get
into the clinic we can study healthy
controls we can study patients with
depression with simultaneous tms and eeg
recordings on the scalp i'll explain
this in a little bit
and then we have the new kid on the
block which i'll present here and that's
tms ieeg
which is basically a combination of
these two methodologies where we utilize
a tms coil
in these epilepsy patients and we can
record with really high signal to noise
the intracranial local field potential
response
and the hope is that we can go back and
forth between these methodologies which
can be hugely beneficial
so we start with the leftmost and
explore how novel treatment patterns may
change the brain in a ground truth type
manner then we bring that up to tmsceg
and see if we can explore and measure
those changes that we see inside the
brain
in the clinic after a clinical trial we
may see that there's some
eeg response that changes in an active
tms group and we want to explore the
underlying neurophysiology of that we
can bring that back down
to the leftmost methodology and explore
where in the brain and what brain
signals
correlate or relate to those
non-invasive measurements
so i hope to start intracranially and
then bring you guys up non-invasively
so intracranially as i mentioned before
we have grid
and strip and depth electrodes that are
implanted into the brain of these
epilepsy patients and we can localize
where these electrodes are based on a
pre-operative mri and a post-op ct
we helped disseminate an approach called
corticocortical of those potentials or
ccep mapping
which is a causal and directional way to
probe human brain connectivity
very simply we apply single pulses of
electrical stimulation in a biphasic and
bipolar manner and measure the evoked
potentials at other regions of the brain
we measure the latency and the amplitude
of those potentials and get a sense of
how connected these brain regions are
we can use these networks
measured with ccps and relate those to
seizure networks we can relate those to
other
non-invasive
non-causal methods of functional
connectivity like resting fmri
and we can use these tools to probe
brain excitability after some
intervention
so in this study here we have one
patient just to show you we apply
stimulation in the dlpsc and record in
the parietal region
this is a single trace of ccep mapping
where we're applying single pulses of
electrical stimulation and you can see
the strong invoke potential about 30
milliseconds afterwards on a single
trial level
when you ask where in the brain do you
see those devoted responses you see them
locally and in more distant and
connected regions
so then we apply our intervention and in
this case it was 10 hertz stimulation we
mimicked this 10 hertz pattern
like tms so 5 seconds on 10 seconds off
3 000 total pulses
and then using ccps after stimulation we
asked what brain regions changed how
long lasting were those changes
we just look at this one region in the
parietal lobe we see this type of
response
what you see is a suppression
of the evo potential or modulation of
the above potential that lasts for about
20 minutes
we were able to predict which brain
regions across a group of about 14
patients which brain regions would
change
based on the anatomical distance from
the stimulation site and the functional
connectivity at baseline from the
strength of the evoked potentials
in the second study we dove into the 10
hertz stimulation itself and we were
able to monitor the votes potential
after each stimulation pulse
asking questions like how does a single
train of 50 pulses modulate the evo
potential throughout the train
how do repeated trains of stimulation
cause the evo potential to evolve during
this treatment pattern and we can fill
in these blanks
so like i mentioned before
not just in summary
i hope to have shown you that this
electrical stimulation approach it can
be a powerful combination with maximal
focality and recording signal to noise
that with the ccp approach we can probe
brain changes after tms pattern
stimulation
and that 10 hertz electrical stimulation
patterned like tms induces brain changes
for about 20 minutes
and these brain changes are predictable
now going up one step in the
translational path
we want to do a similar type study but
use tms coils so we want to explore the
local and downstream neural effects of
single pulse tms in humans
using these brain recordings that have
high spatial and temporal resolution
so that's where tms ieg comes in
this is a long-standing collaboration
that i have recently joined hiroki oya
the university of iowa has performed all
of the phantom brain testing
and aaron boas down at the university of
iowa has managed the patients and
performed the tms experiments from the
last 20 epilepsy patients down there
a rotating grad student in my lab
jeffrey wang was looking for a project
and i was speaking to aaron at that
point in time and we decided to
collaborate and jeffrey's been working
on all of the data analysis
so this is hiroki's work
in terms of the phantom brain we need to
make sure that this is a safe approach
to apply tms pulses
with electrodes placed into the brain
the summary here is that
tms did not cause any heating within the
electrodes
cms did not displace any of the
electrodes even close to the coil
and tms induced gradients in the
electrodes that were safe
they then started
taking these implanted patients and
applying tms
and in the last 20 patients
that have received a variety of
stimulation patterns
no adverse events have occurred
and no seizures were observed because of
participation in these studies
so in a subset of these 20 patients we
were able to apply single pulses of tms
to the dorsolateral prefrontal cortex
which is the treatment site for
depression
so we applied single pulses of tms
50 pulses every two seconds
and we had a sham condition which is a
flipped coil
to get the auditory click
the sense sensory effect
and study that compared to the true tms
direct effect
so we looked at intracranial tms of
votes
potentials this is just one patient
one electrode
where you can see single pulses of tms
to the dlpsc
induce a strong of both potential in
this channel
compared to sham single pulses
there were other channels
where you didn't see much of a
separation
suggesting that this is a sensory effect
and other channels where we saw no
change
whatsoever if you just look at the
single patient and look at the
distribution of tms greater than sham
regions which were regions that showed a
strong
itep
we see this you see a distributed map of
significant brain responses
that were elicited based on tms and not
sham
and then you see these focal
tms equals sham or sensory about
responses which are localized at
bilateral auditory cortices as expected
now the first question we ask here on a
group level is does single pulses of tms
induce local iteps within the dlpsc
so this is a complicated
figure but i want you to focus on the
green dot which was where the tms was
applied
and the black dots which is where we saw
significant of both potentials within
three centimeters of the stimulation
site
now the first thing you can see is you
actually see a lot of white electrodes
which is no separation between tms and
sham
and actually only about 18 of those
electrodes demonstrated this strong itep
effect
we hypothesize that this effect may be
driven by the electrical field strength
that those regions that have a stronger
electrical field from the tms coil
those would be the regions that showed a
strong evo's potential
so this is the electrical field
simulation
and
the percentage of electrodes that were
significant from an itep point of view
you can see that there's some overlap
and sure enough those regions that had a
stronger electrical field did have a
stronger vote response
but the effects were somewhat weak and
the correlation was more like 0.4 so
this
relationship really only explained about
16 percent of the variance
the second question we asked was how
about downstream effects
how does single pulses of tms induce
downstream brain regions if at all
this is what we saw this was eight
subjects what you're seeing here is
ipsilateral brain regions that are
activated or that respond
with significant iteps after single
pulses to the dlpsc
what you can see here is you see the
anterior cingulate cortex the insula and
the dlpfc
light up we saw similar mass
contralaterally
when you plot this on the brain
you see this effect whereas the acc
is the strongest clearest effect
and some in the insula as well
this is just three patients
that have examples of those iteps in the
acc after single pulses to the dlpsc
so this is interesting
the worry that we had here was that this
was all
saliency that the acc and insula are in
the saliency network so is tms just
inducing
uh these evo potentials in these brain
regions purely because the tms pulse is
salient
so we did a couple control analyses the
first one was looking at the functional
connectivity
the resting functional connectivity
between the dlpsc and this acc
so what you're seeing here is where
the iteps were strong after single
pulses to the dlpsc
the dlpsc seed is where the stimulation
site was
and the outline in black is where there
were strong iteps
and this in this subset of patients
we saw strong functional connectivity in
the same brain regions in the acc
suggesting that there's a strong
functional connection there
across all brain regions we also saw
this that those that showed a stronger
itep effect
also had stronger functional
connectivity
we further examined the steel psc acc
interaction using our electrical
stimulation ccep mapping
so in two patients that had the tms
experiments and electrical stimulation
experiments
we applied single pulse electrical
stimulation to the dlpsc and explored
responses in the acc
this is what we saw so
single pulses to the dlpsc did elicit
strong and both responses in that same
acc region
and finally we performed a parietal
stimulation control
so again if these dlpsc responses
if these responses to dlpsctms really
just activating the salient network and
this is just painful stimulation
we should see a similar response with
parietal stimulation
and here the parietal tms does
have a widespread activation pattern
but doesn't activate
those acc regions
so i hope to have shown you that tmsieg
is safe
that you do induce local
evoc responses
but it's only about 20 of the electrodes
and only somewhat explained by the
electrical field
however tms does reliably evoke
downstream responses in the acc and
insula
and that these two regions are
functionally connected
defined through resting functional mri
and electrical stimulation
and a positive parietal tms does not
show this activation pattern
so there's a lot more to do here
including research-grade amplifiers that
will allow us to look within the first
25 milliseconds after the single pulses
of tms
those response curves
dissecting the sham stimulation a little
bit better
and exploring the neural effects of
single and repetitive tms trains
now
i'm going to move fully non-invasively
and
move out to the 30 000 foot view and
talk about treatment
and research that's done in the tms
field
so currently in the clinic
we target the dlpfc using scalp based
targeting methods
on the skull
we dose
based on motor thresholding
and then multiplying that by 1.2 or 120
percent of the motor threshold
and we treat in an open label way
for 30 days
research in this field
targeting is a really hot topic
and
shawn zubiki mike fox nolan williams
ellie cole have pioneered this space
where
they think that there is a specific spot
within the dlpfc
that is functionally connected to other
brain circuits in their case the
subgenuine cortex
that will allow for better treatment
response
dosage is the research going on there is
there's discussions about adjusting the
dose based on the scalp to cortex
uh distance that if there's a large
larger distance you should
treat with more than 120
um
and
treatment research is around the number
of treatments per day that's the big
advances and nolan williams and others
have shown that applying 10 treatments a
day
can complete
a an entire treatment protocol within a
week
and show really nice clinical results
so our research lab takes a slightly
different approach
we believe in the targeting of the dlpsc
but we think we can do this in the
clinic with tms eeg
we dose but we are dosing
based on this multi-dimensional tuning
curve
so we're finding those stimulation
parameters that push around this
potential biomarker maximally and that's
our starting point in terms of treatment
and then in a closed-loop adaptive way
we can update those stimulation patterns
as we go
dive into a little bit more detail here
currently we're doing open loop
stimulation no eeg recordings no fmri
recordings
it's one size fits all it's blind to
one's physiology or plasticity
i hope to move towards to this version
2.0 which is adaptive and closed loop
where we start with a certain pattern
but by recording the eeg
we can update those responses
and so this would be updating the
treatment based on the biomarker changes
based on one physiology and plasticity
and it will hopefully be faster and much
more effective
so we develop this biomarker and move
towards real-time solutions using
tms-eeg
we can simultaneously perturb a brain
region using tms
and measure that brain response with
millisecond temporal resolution this is
a clinic ready tool that is relatively
inexpensive
we've developed automated artifact
rejection
tools to allow us to clean the signal
i'm not going to go into detail but we
get these multi-peak evo potentials
when you plot this on the brain you get
these beautiful maps
of causal brain responses
didn't fully show the right way but is
really the first time non-invasively in
human neuroscience where you can get
causal and directional maps of brain
connectivity
so using tms eeg we want to develop this
brain biomarker where we're bringing
biomers to track brain change that
relates to clinical symptoms
we want to understand how stimulation
parameters affect brain biomarkers
and then we want this real-time
monitoring and closed-loop adaptive
treatment solutions
so in terms of the biomarker
we want to find something with really
high signal to noise
that measures brain excitability
is quantifiable in the clinic
and changes with tms treatment
we think we might have one of those
markers call it the p30
with p30 after a single pulse of dms
when you record the eeg in the local
area of the tms
you see this positive response p for
positive 30 for 30 milliseconds
again that localizes
to the ipsilateral side of stimulation
and is thought to reflect local ability
we know this from pharmacology studies
where when you add a a voltage sensitive
sodium channel blocker you can decrease
that p25 or p30
we also see this measurement within
intracranial eeg i showed you this map
before but within 20 to 40 milliseconds
you see a first deflection
of the votes response after a single
pulse of electrical stimulation
so we have three lines of evidence to
suggest that the p30 might be a
potential biomarker to move forward with
the first is a randomized clinical trial
in depression where we randomize
patients to either four weeks of real
tms
or four weeks of sham tms and we
measured before versus after using
tms-eeg we measure these devote
potentials we perform this analysis at
every peak and we only saw significant
effects at the p30.
the effects that we saw was a group by
time effect group being
active versus sham time being previous
post treatment
we saw this effect locally in the left
prefrontal region where we were treating
and in the left parietal region
when you break this effect down we saw a
significant effect of time
in the active but not the sham treatment
the p30 actually gets suppressed
after treatment in the active but not
the sham group
and this p30 is localized to medial and
lateral prefrontal cortexes
now although it's a small study with a
relatively weak effect we also saw
that the degree of the p30 suppression
related
in the active group to the degree of
clinical improvement
again low correlation take that with a
grain of salt
the second study we have is a single day
tms study with healthy controls where we
performed a single day of 10 hertz
stimulation
and saw again a suppression of this p30
in the parietal region
on the left side and didn't see that in
a control
v1
the third line of evidence is the
intracranial work that i showed you
before that i'm not going to repeat but
we saw a modulation of the above
potential around 30 milliseconds
in regions predicted based on anatomical
and functional connectivity
so this is great
but the problem with the p30 is it has
extremely low signal to noise it's just
really low amplitude it's very close to
the single pulse
so mechanistically we can start to
understand it
but
it has it has low uh
low voltage
so how do we improve upon that so any
time you have low signal to noise the
two ways that you boost the signal's
noise are by reducing the noise or
increasing the signal so we're going to
try to do both
so in this study we're reducing the
noise
it's well known that tms induces many
off-target sensory responses unrelated
to the direct effects of tms
this manifests in the n or negativity at
100 milliseconds and p positivity is 200
milliseconds but the auditory vote
potential can really start as early as
30 milliseconds
so we need to remove this to get sound
interpretation of our results
so we perform the study in 21 healthy
controls the goal is to minimize this
vertex n100 p200
we use standard masking in the field
so typical
metrics typical methods are taking the
auditory click
from the tms and playing it continuously
that's noise masking and using a foam
that separates the tmf coil from the
skull to minimize bone conduction
we added two more pieces here one was
earmuffs these are passive
noise reducing headphones that
construction workers and others will use
to reduce the sound effects
of dms before it gets masked
and
the inter-stimulus interval timing so
typically you apply about 100 or 200 of
these single pulses and then average
them to get the evo potential
these are typically jittered
to reduce the potential that there is a
plasticity effect over these hundred
pulses
we showed in our studies at least we
didn't see that plasticity effect
if we didn't jitter
and we hypothesized that by jittering
you're increasing the saliency of the
signal and so therefore increasing the
n100 and p200
the bottom line here is in this
attenuate protocol as we call it we were
able to suppress this n100 and p200
considerably compared to standard
masking techniques
we also were able to
reduce the scalp sensation and loudness
that participants
perceived
so the other way to boost snr is to
increase the signal
and these are just two very early
studies
but you can do this two different ways
you can do this analytically or
experimentally
so analytically just to give you a sense
of this single pulses of dlpsc tms and
measuring with the scalp eg
you see this type of response
each color is a different brain region
all i want you to get from this
trace
is that within this 30 millisecond time
period
it's really complicated
and what people typically do is pick one
metric let's say the peak from 25 to 35
milliseconds in this brain region to
explore further
but there's lots of information in there
that we're missing so i think a
multivariate approach
will be more valuable in extracting
relevant features
and boosting that signal to noise
so i'm not going to go into detail but
we're exploring the following analytic
considerations including what time
window do you choose
what peak picking method
we look in time or frequency space and
finally region of interest if we just
look at region of interest
it's
complicated we can look at a single
channel or multiple channels we can look
in sensor or source space
and finally we can go back to the
experiment itself and say let's get a
higher signal to noise to begin with and
so we're doing a grid search and an
angle search around the dlpsc to find
what angle and location boosts the p30
the best
so i hope to have shown you that this
p30 is present intracranially and
non-invasively it reflects cortical
excitability it gets suppressed after a
single day and after four weeks of
treatment
and it may be related to clinical
outcome
and finally we think we can boost the
signal to noise by suppressing sensory
potentials and optimizing experimental
and analytic approaches
so
once we potentially have this biomarker
we need to explore the stimulation
parameter space
just to give you an idea here this is
what 10 hertz treatment looks like where
each line represents a stimulation train
each row represents a stimulation
session or a day
it is impossible
to compare this treatment to five other
treatments in the same individual
we need to reduce
the dimensions here
we need to ask simple questions like do
single tms trains elicit acute brain
changes quantifiable with the eg
how long lasting are these changes
how do these changes differ based on
different stimulation parameters
and how do these changes build with
repeated stimulation trains
we'll explore 10 hertz but we'll also
look at one hertz and theta burst we'll
also look at this unexplored space
this is the multiple dimensions that i
showed you before we're going to start
by tackling the three most simplest ones
we're going to look at a single
stimulation train and measure the
electrophysiology
and then we're going to break that train
down
and explore this multi-dimensional
tuning curve
and ask questions like how does this
tuning curve differ based on location
between subjects how does it differ
after an intervention
how does it differ when you add multiple
repeated trains
with lots of different avenues that this
can go and is necessary in order to
develop closed loop solutions
and on that
once we potentially have the biomarker
once we understand how that biomarker is
pushed around with various stimulation
parameters
we can then start to think about these
different closed-loop algorithms
so we've developed a methodology to
clean and monitor these early biomarkers
in real time this is in close
collaboration with scott linderman in
the statistics department
we are currently testing these close-up
algorithms bayesian optimization
reinforcement learning control systems
theory in silicon and vivo to
demonstrate the proof of concept
and then we will be applying these
algorithms to evaluate single day brain
changes
and then multi-day brain changes and
then explore those brain changes as they
relate to clinical symptoms
but i hope to have shown you that
interventional psychiatry is this
emerging field with tons of potential
but we have a ways to go
we need to develop and refine these
brain biomarkers map these biomarkers to
stimulation parameters and then develop
these closed loop treatment solutions
and then we'll have personalized
treatment that we can apply to any brain
circuit and any neuropsychiatric
disorder
i want to thank you all for listening
i want to thank everyone that made this
happen
this is a huge group approach everyone
in the lab all the research participants
collaborators and funding agencies
thank you for your time
you